das hier ist unser alter freund die
doppel batterie oder auch mignon stella
sie ist super praktisch und vielseitig
einsetzbar leider lassen sich solche
batterien aber je nach ausführung nicht
mehr aufladen
ergo ist sie einmal leer und wird sie
unbrauchbar dieses problem lösen
lithium-ionen-akkus nun leider haben die
einen anderen haken jeder akku verliert
beim auf- und entladen ein kleines
bisschen seiner kapazität
was aber wenn wir einen akku hätten mit
denen ein handy viel schneller
aufgeladen wäre und der sieben mal so
lange hält das wäre natürlich ein traum
für verbraucher industrie und die
wissenschaft so ein stromspeicher wurde
nicht nur unseren alltag erleichtern
sondern auch zu völlig neuen
innovationen führen und tatsächlich
scheint ihr diese lang erwartete
evolution des akkus endlich da zu sein
bevor ich euch aber vom akku der zukunft
erzähle hier noch ein ganz kurzer
hinweis ich bin ab jetzt regelmäßig auf
dem kanal von geno zu sehen und spreche
dort über elektromobilität im
allgemeinen und vor allem über
elektroautos wie sie funktionieren wie
sauber sie tatsächlich sind und welche
autos in meinen augen gerade am
spannendsten sind am ende von diesem
video hier erzähle ich euch gerne noch
ein bisschen mehr über dieses neue
format aber wenn ihr den kanal jetzt
schon abonnieren wollt dann findet ihr
unten in der video beschreibung einen
link dazu
[Musik]
im letzten video habe ich über das
wundermaterial graphen gesprochen
es ist stärker als stahl leichter als
luft und leitet strom beinahe ohne
widerstand und man kann es in vielen
verschiedenen bereichen einsetzen einer
davon ist eine verbesserte akku
technologie namhafte hersteller haben
uns schon seit jahren hoffnung gemacht
dass wir bald in den genuss der batterie
2.0 kommen werden
leider ist auf diese ankündigungen lange
nichts gefolgt bis jetzt einem
hersteller scheint es geglückt zu sein
die erste echte graffin batterie auf den
markt zu bringen
das ist eine kleine power bank mit
10.000 oder 20.000 milliamperestunden
und der hersteller zeigt sich
zuversichtlich dass man innerhalb des
nächsten jahres schon solche akkus auch
in die verschiedensten geräte einbauen
kann zum beispiel handys laptops oder
sogar autos aber warum sind graffin
akkus so etwas besonderes wie
funktionieren sie an dieser stelle muss
ich erst mal ein missverständnis aus dem
weg räumen so etwas wie die eine graffin
batterie gibt es nicht und schon der
begriff graffin batterie ist etwas
irreführend denn so entsteht im kopf
schnell ein bild von einem fundamentalen
neuen produkt der unterschied zu
traditionellen modellen ist aber
tatsächlich viel geringer als man denkt
denn interessanterweise sind zumindest
bisher vorgestellte graffin batterien
einfach modifizierte herkömmliche
batterien
sie haben zwei elektroden und eine
elektrolytlösung für den
millionentransfer bis hierhin alles ganz
normal
der unterschied wird deutlich wenn man
sich die zusammensetzung von einer oder
beiden elektroden der batterie anschaut
in einer traditionellen batterie besteht
die kathode meist aus materialien wie
graphit kobalt oder nickel in einer
graffin batterie hingegen besteht sie
aus einem graffin hybridmaterial der
korrekte begriff für solche batterien
wäre also ergriffen enhanced battery
also graffin verbesserte batterie der
einfachheit halber werde ich aber in
diesem video einfach von graphen
batterien sprechen und wenn wir schon
mal dabei sind ja batterien und akkus
sind eigentlich zwei verschiedene dinge
im deutschen aber hat man benutzt ja im
alltag eigentlich beides synonym und
deswegen werde ich das in diesem video
hier auch machen
das einbinden von graffin in die kathode
löst du einige probleme von
herkömmlichen batterien
nehmen wir hierfür mal als beispiel die
lithium-ionen-batterie das ist quasi die
standard batterie für laptops
smartphones und sogar für elektroautos
zu den defiziten von solchen batterien
zählt dass sie altern und mit dem alter
verlieren sie auch an performance durch
eine chemische reaktion mit der
elektrolytlösung formt sich eine art
schutzschicht auf der elektrode diese
schutzschicht hat aber auch einen
negativen effekt von ladezyklus zu
ladezyklus wird die schicht immer etwas
dicker und verringert so stück für stück
die kapazität des akkus
das geht so lange bis der akku
irgendwann nicht mehr genug energie
halten kann um nützlich zu sein und dann
schmeißt man ihn weg oder recycelt in
hoffentlich sie zeigt aber graffin seine
stärke denn durch grafen muss weniger
graphit in den elektroden verbaut werden
so fungiert das café quasi als ein
schutz der kathode
das verringert einerseits chemische
reaktionen mit der elektrolytlösung
nebenbei sorgt auf ihn aber auch für
eine größere oberfläche
das erhöht die leitfähigkeit so dass die
elektroden kleiner gebaut werden können
dieser dazu gewonnene raum bedeutet dass
ein akku mit derselben größe bis zu 45
prozent mehr energie speichern kann und
laut hersteller kann man graphen akkus
bis zu fünfmal schneller laden noch das
kommt durch die verbesserte
leitfähigkeit
ein weiteres defizit von
lithium-ionen-batterien ist die
sicherheitsrisiko denn solche batterien
können schnell überhitzen
viele von euch erinnern sich bestimmt
noch an die galaxy note sevens die vor
ein paar jahren manchmal spontan in
flammen aufgegangen sind und für richtig
gute stimmung in flugzeugen gesorgt
haben graphen reduziert dieses risiko
dass bleibt nämlich auch unter hohen
belastungen kühl und mit reduziert die
gefahr dass die batterie überhitzt und
feuer fängt
aber nicht nur lithium ionen batterien
können von graffin profitieren
wissenschaftler sehen zum beispiel auch
super kondensatoren als kandidaten für
einen grafen tuning diese nutzen zum
speichern von energie eine statische
aufladung für die elektroden wird hier
bisher meist aktivkohle genutzt würde
diese durch graffin ersetzt werden
können superkondensatoren mit bisher
undenkbaren spannungen arbeiten
okay das klingt ja alles megacool
kriegen also bald alle geräte mit einem
akku einen kaffee ein update
graphit ist momentan noch sehr teuer
langsam wird es zwar günstiger aber je
nach verfahren ist die herstellung mehr
oder weniger kompliziert kostet mehr
oder weniger ressourcen und ist vor
allem noch nicht bereit für eine
massenproduktion
hinzu kommt dass sich bisher noch kein
verfahren als branchenstandard
durchgesetzt hat wie graffin am besten
verwendet wird firmen arbeiten an
verschiedenen arten der kohlenstoff
modifikationen die auf unterschiedliche
weisen in akkus eingesetzt werden können
samsung hat zum beispiel für eine
batterie mit hilfe von siliziumoxid
kleine graffin bälle hergestellt und
angeblich soll so eine batterie nicht
teurer sein als herkömmliche lithium
ionen batterien
diese ankündigung kam aber schon 2016
seitdem herrscht um das konzept
funkstille
jetzt gibt es ja aber die erste
marktfähige grafikpower bank und diese
kann uns hoffnung machen das nach und
nach wege gefunden werden
erschwingliche batterien auf den markt
zu bringen die dann vielleicht auch in
der nächsten oder vielleicht auch erst
im übernächsten smartphone verbaut sein
werden solche produkte bieten uns
sozusagen einen kleinen vorgeschmack
darauf was durch graffin alles möglich
sein wird
bisherige werte wenn es um lebensdauer
speichervermögen und aufladen geht
könnten noch viel besser werden das ist
für smartphones und laptops super aber
für elektroautos ist das
überlebenswichtig wie alltagstauglich
ihr auto sind hängt direkt damit
zusammen wie viel energie der akku
speichern kann und wie schnell man das
auto an der tankstelle wieder aufladen
kann
schon heute gibt es viele elektroautos
die in meinen augen zumindest absolut
alltagstauglich sind und beim fahren
sogar noch mehr spaß machen als
herkömmliche verbrenner aber wenn die
akkus noch besser werden dann sind die
tage von benzin und diesel bald gezählt
und akkus werden immer besser auch ohne
grafen also sind die tage von benzin und
diesel gezählt also folgt mir auf den
kanal von yello und lasst uns lieber e
mobilität sprechen
dort gibt es reviews reportagen und news
mit mir und bald auch ganz ganz vielen
anderen youtube an
im neuen video erzähle ich euch wie der
aktuelle stand von e autos im jahr 2020
aussieht dass videos gerade ganz frisch
online gegangen also schaut euch an
dafür einfach hier klicken und ansonsten
wie immer dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt
neugierig neuester trick